This episode of "Shots of Awe"
is brought to you by Toyota.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So I'm really into the
topic of serendipity.
Moments of unexpected relevance.
Moments in which you find
yourself looking for something
and find something else.
And what you realize
is that what you found
is more conducive to
your needs than what
you thought you
were looking for.
And Erik Davis says
that serendipity
lives in the space
of juxtaposition,
in the space of diversity.
He says that juxtaposition
is the basic formal operating
space of serendipity,
the space in which you're
more likely to make unexpected
connections between subjects,
the spaces in which ideas, a
rich diversity, a rich ecology
of stimulant ideas can
intermingle and create
these spaces of
innovation in your head
from just finding these unusual
combinations among subject
matter.
And he talks about places
like the city, which
has density and this diversity
of viewpoints, perspectives,
and memes.
This supermarket of memes
that creates these unexpected
collisions and creates
that creativity.
But he also talks about
places like Burning Man, just
this festival where
juxtaposition reigns supreme.
Where a piano against
some stark desert contrast
is next to like some
overgrown dice alluding
to like some Alice in
Wonderland-esque rat rabbit
hole, next to something
like crazy naked girl.
And a juxtaposition
floods you with dopamine,
floods you with novelty.
And just awakens
this lightning bolt
of meaning in the
perceiver's mind.
This heightened
pattern recognition,
that rush that we
associate with creativity.
So again, it's all
about juxtaposition.
The juxtaposition
of extremes creates
that basic formal operating
space of serendipity.
[MUSIC PLAYING]